and USA Today reports how teachers who
strike our earning high grades a new USA
Today if Zoe's poll finds that 66% of
Americans believe public schoolteachers
have the right to strike that number
even includes parents whose lives are
most disrupted when the school is an in
session the poll and story are part of
our new series school matters CBS this
morning is partnering with USA Today to
feature extended stories and
investigations on education over the
next nine months we'll go inside America
schools to find out what matters most to
students teachers and parents Susan page
co-wrote today's story and talked to
some of the 2000 Americans polled she's
USA TODAY's Washington bureau chief and
joins us now good morning hey Josh so
tell me about this support for teachers
who walk out it's bipartisan that's
right you know Americans hate strikes
and they hate strikes by public
employees in particular but they support
the idea of teacher striking two-thirds
of parents who have kids in public
schools today say yes I support the
right of teachers to strike because I
think there is a sense that we don't pay
teachers enough they have a tough job we
now expect them to do everything from
raising students scores to protecting
students in mass shootings and you talk
to people you didn't just look at the
poll numbers so what came through in
those conversations you know it's the
incredible reverence that Americans have
for teachers a recognition of the role
they got the role they play we asked
Americans did a teacher make a
significant positive impact in your own
life and three out of four Americans say
yes and they're still held in such high
regard aren't they when you look at all
the professions out there teachers are
still highly ranked you know we asked
Americans in a previous poll what are
the best things about America and the
number one the number three thing was
teachers the only thing that did better
was nurses and kindness to strangers
until your teachers did a lot better
than say journalists so here's what
you're saying because you cover who and
you cover politics is that if there's
it's rare to get an overwhelming
majority in this country to degree on
agree on one thing and it's in this case
it's 2/3 day they should get paid more
so why isn't there a political movement
behind that a powerful one but you know
we've seen the effect of that we saw
teachers strike in the spring and some
Republican leaning some red states like
Oklahoma and West Virginia
they did well they won state legislators
including Republicans who don't like to
spend money who don't like to raise
taxes supported them because as we found
in this poll there is almost no partisan
difference when it comes to supporting
the idea that investment in education
makes sense and that teachers are not
paid enough but they don't mind the
striking but they don't they say Troy
King is okay but they don't seem to
support unions you know there's some
words there's more of a division about
unions and the thing that Americans
don't like about teachers unions they
think they protect bad teachers enable
bad teachers to say in class there's so
few issues where there is a bipartisan
agreement on them let me ask you this
people sometimes like their congressman
and don't like Congress people like
their teachers what do they think about
the Department of Education you know
there's a real division if you look for
partisan differences in this poll
they're only a couple and one is on
views of the Department of Education but
almost evenly approve or disapprove and
there's a in the different series
Republicans approve of the Department of
Education Democrats disapprove I think
that reflects attitudes toward the Trump
administration right which is reversed
historically yeah that's right usually
it's Republicans who don't like the
Department of Education as much as
Democrats Susan page thank you so much
hey thank you you wrote that memo Susan
Washington you got sources but okay
another story I digress here we go thank
you for the partnership to do it